Singapore
[Music]
you can kind of hear it
it's coming through you hear that sound
slightly coming through coming from from
very far away and now it's not making
any more sense the faint guitar welcomes
us back to another episode of the
corridor podcast thanks for being here
episode one seven one we've got the
whole gang Nico's got some extra Tunes
coming in
what's going on everybody I've got I've
got Nico Sam and Nick joining me here
today thanks for joining us what's going
on everybody my alarm just went off
no I just it was like it's 4 39 p.m I'm
like okay dude last night or something
that you you set that alarm for and
you've forgotten but it's really
important anyway it did so like it muted
everybody and like I have my earpods in
my ears right now so I'm doing like the
passenger that turned off it was very
disorienting because it also looks like
Island music starts blasting in my head
welcome to the island man yeah that's
like the laziest form of me reminding
myself of something is I just set an
alarm for something without labeling it
and then when it goes off I'm like oh
God what was I supposed to do
yeah no you just say remind me to do
this at 5 pm and then you get the
reminder and it's like gibberish and
you're like all right
what did that say like what did that
translate to yeah what was I thinking I
feel like that's the key to a successful
life in your like 30s and 40s is
constantly using your phone reminders to
remind you when you need to do something
yeah yeah not relying on your brain in
memory you're relying on your brain I
don't do that I'm not I don't do that
one
yeah well I must be the only guest all
day long
Jake has actually his Post-it notes on
his computer I do use well see the thing
is I'm I'm when I'm not at the studio
I'm at my desk when I'm working and so I
literally just use Post-it notes like
all day yeah it's the same thing it's
the same thing I just I posted notes on
my phone right but it probably if I was
up and about more
it would be more useful probably
yeah
I don't know but I wonder what the
thumbnail of this podcast looks like and
what the title is but if there's
anything about anime rock paper scissors
then uh come to the right place
oh so you're starting Title First
without knowing the title yeah yeah yeah
that's how we've been doing the podcasts
lately podcast yeah so uh hey guess what
we're working on episode two of anime
rock paper scissors yeah surprise if you
follow our Instagram you're probably
well aware of this because there's no
pictures of me and Dean looking goofy as
heck
yeah we also are doing a whole Vlog on
it uh yeah on quarter digital following
everything yeah there's a couple so far
yeah so uh
yeah we're uh did the beard work did the
beard did you or you might be your
shavier Okay so
so there's uh there's a saying in
Hollywood which is never to film with
children or animals and Sam wrote this
wonderful scene for the beginning of
anime rock paper scissors too where's
the Two Princes as children which is
basically you know it it we saw this
brief flashback at the end of rock paper
scissors one it was enriching it just
showed us there was depth in this world
yeah where did this world come from
well I mean this is just like your
classic fantasy world your power
struggles you know it's a tale of
Brothers it's like we don't know the
year is it 1400 1500 it's kind of 1800s
at times sometimes eight hundreds it's
like that anime like kind of European
vague style where yeah yeah they have
corsets and like it's medieval and like
Victorian architecture at the same time
it's like the ren Fair it's like this
no [__] steampunk at all
anything between
1200 years and 17. 1800 is okay yep
yeah but it's so funny the big takeaway
of that it was Dean who told me this but
he said he you know played the video for
his girlfriend and then she was like oh
wow at the end when she saw this it was
like the silly Corridor Digital push
yeah I filmed it like alone
I filmed it alone I took an iPhone down
to the green screen alone filmed all the
plates and then generated images of like
anime boys with mid-journey and we just
constructed that as like it was a joke
push it wasn't that much I mean it's
semi-joke push it was like you know it's
a push but it's like come on why let's
just keep the guy going a little longer
yeah and then but Dean was saying that
his girlfriend watched it and then
um
when that came up even though it's like
me saying go to Corridor digital.com she
was like
they used to be little boys
they're just friends I don't know
they're so innocent we're so innocent
now they hate each other and they one
killed their father you know it was like
she had that like emotional moment right
right and I was just like holy [__] like
you tapped into something like the
classic tale of two brothers hating each
other I know yeah it's as old as
Humanity yeah so I was like yo because
then we were just joking I'm like hey
yeah what if they like played the game
for their soul
not really spoilers don't worry about it
but anyways yeah so yeah it's really
funny I can't believe it works though it
like just Nico as a well that's a holy
adult man
just the intro
we can't go upset that fast we have to
tantalize people along the way people
okay as I mentioned explain it
right Never filmed with kids or animals
is what people say why it's a hassle
it's very hard to get what you want and
so Samurai is a scene where there's two
children it's like okay
so kids I don't want to deal with like
doing voice recording for kids and then
deal with acting for kids and trying to
teach them how this whole like process
works where you're going to pretend
you're you're basically puppeteering an
anime character with your face and your
body
um but you're like you know what if we
have the world's most Cutting Edge
machine learning algorithms de-aging
machine learning algorithm we should be
able to just do it ourselves as in like
me and Dean if we can if you can play
anime princess
theoretically we can play anime boys
and there's a caveat which is we have to
wear generally what we're what get gets
transformed on camera right if you want
to have you know long red hair in the
final picture you need to have a long
red hair wig on when you film yourself
but
a boy does not have a beard that's the
same goes
except for that one kid in your high
school
it was like the beard kid we all got it
yeah yeah
no this is not me dude
in college without a beard yeah my beard
didn't come into I was 19.
um
yeah so
I really didn't want to shave
why not because I think I look really
goofy without a beard it also like I'm
on camera a lot like it sounds pompous
to say like I feel like every week and
like a million people watch these videos
and if I'd shave my beer that would
concern I guess if I shave my beard a
million people have to see people are
gonna recognize me
I don't want to look I want to be out
there beardless I want to be out there
you got to go my map change your facial
hair all the time and then nobody knows
what you're gonna look like next that's
what I do yeah but you know James the
saying goes a boy does not have a beard
that is the same that is that is the
name of the podcast I think anime
this is just too a boy does not have a
beard there's a simple truth in life the
boy does not have a beard so uh so he
popped the wig on my head and I put the
costume on and we said screw it and he
filmed me anyways with a beard without
doing any tests
yeah there was a test that was done and
it was the day we started filming so
everyone gets in the costume and we're
about to roll a shot and then they
forgot to shake it and then I was like
Nico you didn't like at least like [__]
up you know or something and so like I
guess what you should do a test and so
we go all right let's not I was
literally I'm taking my finger off the
record button
yeah
and the test worked great it turns out
you can have a beard and it's insane so
it's not it's not creating it's not
creating you know weird shading every
different frame no it's the only kind of
weird thing is sometimes my mouth is
open when it's closed because it's
drawing it's taking my mustache as the
mouth rather than my mouth as the mouth
have you seen them not that one that's
it it's almost like too much without a
beard yeah
I'm showing them some boyish pictures
that's very boyish yeah basically what
we discovered is that like
when you're training in so when we've
made the first rock paper scissors you
know we had our style set we had some
some drama around our style set even
though you know for the past decade
we've literally just taking inspiration
from IPS and properties and characters
at will for YouTube videos because it's
different now
yeah
yeah no whatever
um anyways so we took our style set for
the first one we you know kind of made
pictures of us
and that was it but we discovered that
if you just have only pictures of your
characters in their final look
in your data set when you train your
model it works really well so we just
have all these young pictures of a very
generic boyish anime Nico and generic
I'd say how did you get that no he's
very striking he's not he's not generic
whatsoever in Seoul like in terms of his
face it's your very average like anime
like big eyes anime nose anime triangle
chin so to get those pictures though you
guys just took some photos and ran it
through yeah dream booth and just said
like boy like pretty much and then when
you found the ones you like that were
consistent well we took a lot of
pictures of ourselves and we we
basically generated like these anime
like transmutations of ourselves and now
we're just taking that data set for the
boy copy and because of that
like because there's no beards in the
data set because it's only one face in
the data set like we're not doing all
this other stuff we get kind of used to
do in the past well we a little bit it's
like we're very much an experimentation
territory still but like because we just
trained in only pictures of this boy
with these features with that costume
and only those pictures now now I can
even have a beard and I don't have to
have the character have a beard you're
folding steel dude like a Japanese
swordsmith you're training AI on AI
images to create your own data sets yes
we're guessing and figuring it out as we
go now
it should be it should mention we are
actually doing our own style set for
disclaimer rock paper scissors
disclaimer for for anybody who somebody
disclaimed round from disclaimer Game
Over Georgia yeah I just hate watching
this podcast right now yeah there might
be a couple if your cheeks are getting
red steam's starting to come out of the
years steam is starting to billow out of
your ears we have news for you
the first one we did without even
knowing if it would work so we didn't
make our own data set but this time we
made our own dates yes
let me let me tee you up here for this
what's flipping it okay for anime rock
paper scissors too we are doing
something once again that no one has
done before oh that's really nice this
time it's
completely ethical
so you know with rock paper scissors one
we learned how to train in style said we
learned that this would even work in the
first place which many people are like
how dare you I was like what I'm going
to do experience people this is why I'm
always everyone said this is sweet
actually you're right you're right it's
so easy to put all your attention on
like the few people that are allowed the
many that are positive and supportive
and it's the many that are positive and
supportive that really deserve your
mental attention the problem is is that
point one percent of two million viewers
is still a lot of people
I have a theory about this did your did
either of your kids say Dad as their
first word
no
okay I don't know why well wait what if
I said yes would that change what you're
about to say no I just two of mine did
and Wendy and I were always trying to
figure this out and I have a theory
about this which relates back to why you
put your attention towards negative
comments instead of majority ones or a a
a small loud minority of comments no
matter what it is versus the majority of
comments yeah and here's the thing it's
like when you're a child and you're born
and all you know is your mother's bosom
and you're you know and then you don't
even know your mom is there you're just
like you're just like social State yeah
you're so attached to your mother at
that point that you you don't even
recognize you're there and then this
other person comes in the room and
you're like hey that's the other that
it's the other thing and then you learn
the word of the other thing before you
learn the word of the thing that's
keeping you alive
just because it's not the thing that
you're so used to yeah it is it's not
the thing you've been attached to yeah
like like because it is you in a way
yeah yeah yeah so anyway that was my
little tangent well some true father
like wisdom right there yeah
so uh so you know we learned how this
whole style thing works like to a
certain degree I mean there's obviously
like a million Mysteries still to
uncover but there's uh it's an old
friend of mine from uh from college
who's uh one of the our fellow art
students Sam and I were going through
the program named Josh Newland and we've
brought him on to basically create a
style for rock paper scissors too he's
drawing the characters kind of Designing
the look
and we're using that now we're using
that to kind of create a new system for
these characters going to the second
episode because I think anybody who's
like jumped onto like any of these
generative tools you know mid-journey
Dolly stable diffusion like it's one
thing to just like type in random stuff
like wow it gave me such a cool picture
when I typed dinosaur wearing sunglasses
you know it's like it's one thing to do
that it's nothing to be like okay now I
actually have a mission I'm somebody
who's somebody asked me to design you
know an advertisement and I need a
picture of like you know a nice Island
beach or something like that you know
it's like you go on you try to generate
it and suddenly you realize like when
you try to do this like
oh now this it doesn't listen to me like
I try to give a direction it's not
giving me what I want it's giving me
what it knows it's like a pretty picture
but like it's not giving me the picture
I want I want a single palm tree in
front of the sunset with like a coconut
lying on the sand it's like No And it's
like I'm not getting what I want yeah
and like that trying to like wrestle
your vision out of these these programs
like that's when you quickly start to
realize the limitations of all the stuff
that it's not magic nor is it about to
uh you know take over the world or
anything like that
um
but in doing so you know when when you
can when you can learn how to add your
own style to this one create your own
characters and bring your own Vision to
life that's when it gets really exciting
and that's what's so exciting about
being able to film ourselves on a green
screen and to process it and turn
ourselves into cartoon characters and
it's even more exciting that we learned
hey we can do this with any style so I
can literally ask my friend to draw
really cool pictures of these characters
and then suddenly they can move and it's
like wow we did that with like you know
10 pictures 15 pictures and like and
like two or three people working on it
it's like that is insane that's so crazy
and so that's that's kind of where we're
headed right now with rock paper
scissors too is trying to figure all
that kind of stuff out and you know make
things look even more cartoony and more
animated and all that good stuff it's
really exciting stuff like it's there's
a whole facet of this that like we're
kind of exploring a little bit in
parallel which is the ability to
automatically ink and color uh drawings
that's because that's that's the crazy
part that I saw where we you just had
that rough sketch it was just like an
outline and it was like kind of messy
Line work too it wasn't like perfectly
clean there's literally a picture from a
Sketchbook yeah photo taken on a phone
from a Sketchbook and then Dean was able
to take it and ink and colorize all of
it yeah so one thing we've just that's
see and this is like the thing that yeah
every time we talk about this I'm like I
feel like this is why it's really really
cool that's more disruptive to animation
I know what you guys did in the first
video honestly a lot of people when I
when I opened up that a quarter crew
video uh did we change animation forever
to be fair it's really the people that
make these tools that change animation
forever but uh
when I said you know we're trying to
democratize animation a lot of people
took that in a lot of different ways but
what I mean by that is that it's it's
hard to make a cartoon it's really hard
like yeah of course anybody can sit down
with a pencil and start drawing in a
flip book I get it like yeah no no crap
anybody can grab a camera and go start
shooting a movie right but the point is
like okay cool can you give me a half an
hour of a finished cartoon like
televisions television quality please
it's like no you're not that's going to
take a team of professionals a long time
to do or even just yeah or one person
democratize yeah oh very long time to do
a very long time to do and they'll have
to be very good and when I say
democratize I mean like hey what if you
could just do it yourself
in a month or two months you know what
if you could what if everybody could
deliver that quality because that's what
happens like that's what's happening
with blender like when you are Unreal
Engine when you pop it on Open Unreal
Engine they democratize video game
making like you are getting the graphic
quality of a triple A video game engine
for free you know anybody can get AAA
Graphics now that's insane like so
that's what that's what I'm saying here
and like it was it was that word in
particular was very divisive yeah yeah
it was but you know it's I we are it is
like this tool is doing that people
don't see it yet and I get it it's a
wacky crazy world out there and like
yeah obviously you need to buy a
computer
but you know it's 2023 it's like well
some people push back on it and it was
like well you guys have all this
expensive equipment that's not
democratized yeah
some expensive equipment but also like
anyone you can do it with a PC anyone I
don't think it's really fair to say that
because it requires a nice computer with
a good graphics card to do something
that used to take a building with a
millions and millions of dollars of
infrastructure is still like Out Of
Reach it's yeah yeah that's like saying
fortnite's not actually free to play
because you have to buy a computer
so they're lying instead right yeah
there's a lot of people who said that
and I just that's it wasn't worth
responding back to other than to say
that sorry to see if we gotta yeah
it's worth mentioning All This is Gonna
Come smelling out I mean there's enough
distance yeah I mean yeah when you're in
my shoes and you're seeing all these a
lot of these comments and you know
there's plenty of valid concerns people
have but there's also a lot of people
that were just angry and a lot of people
just put us into a position that which
we weren't in and they just put us in in
there so they could yell at us and like
it was very frustrating especially when
you know that like when like 90 of the
arguments people are putting out there
are just completely inaccurate and
you're like I'm the kind of person that
likes to have imaginary debates in my
head God I had to like I had to mentally
stop myself over and over and over from
wasting mental energy being like well
this person is wrong and I can write a
thesis as to why like it's like no just
it's like I don't have to bother like
just I'll be quiet it's really hard it's
really it's really hard yeah I slipped
two times and that was it yeah I know I
wrote out an angry comment and like it
then deleted it yeah or later I'm like
this is not productive yeah you're not
gonna there's nothing you're gonna do
about it it's a big wall I know I sent
an email someone sent us an email and I
sent us I was like a stock email back
and I was like oh shouldn't have done
that yeah guess I'm gonna have to block
their email
really should not respond or read their
response yeah yeah I mean here's here's
a there's an old uh there's an old tale
about this about uh a donkey hell yes a
donkey and a tiger okay okay thank you
Jake thank you for your wisdom so
one day a tiger and a donkey are
standing in a field and the donkey looks
up at the sky and says the sky is red
and the Tiger goes
no it's not it's blue and the donkey
goes no it's it's red and they go on and
on and of course the donkey being a
donkey is like no it's red all the way
and they go all right we're gonna go see
the king of the jungle about this we're
we're gonna go see the lion okay and
we're gonna go see the king and they go
to The Lion and the lion goes what's
your complaint and the donkey goes well
I'm the Tiger goes I know the sky is
blue but this donkey keeps thinking that
the sky is red and you gotta tell him
the sky is blue and the donkey goes okay
so which color is the sky and the King
goes the sky is red and he lets the
donkey and he lets the donkey go and he
punishes the tiger and the Tiger's like
why am I in trouble you know the sky is
blue and the the lion goes because you
should know better as a tiger you should
know better than to argue with a donkey
all right well dang so that's one of
those hard-hitting yeah how that's like
2000 year old
I don't know that's one yeah yeah yeah
no one of those no [__] you know no
[__] stories yeah man no you know I
will say like
out of that storm of like you know
Twitter length uh bite-sized outrage
um there were some actual there were
some really nice Reflections in thoughts
critiques perspectives
um you know there's like
there's a fantastic response like Aaron
Blaze one of like uh you know the
directors at Disney he sat down he did a
really deep dive and like talked about
some of the history of like rotoscope he
talked about some history of Technology
what it was like going through like the
3D animation Revolution what is like
going through the digital Revolution for
hand animation and traditional animation
um and just you know a really good
perspective on the art industry because
like
I think everybody's very surprised at
how fast the art medium evolves but just
having only been in the industry
ourselves for maybe almost 20 years now
you know it's like we ourselves have
seen it evolve so intensely in fact it's
that Evolution that even got us into it
in the first place because I remember a
little young Nico paringer and a little
young Sam Gorski getting their very
first digital video cameras in their
hands to play with and their very first
non-linear editors and it was like a oh
this is big deal like this is a big big
change and like suddenly we shot a Star
Wars movie you know and it's on Corridor
right now
um and it is janky as heck but the point
being is that like that evolution of of
the medium and art and technology and
the tools has always been like what's
watered our plants so to speak it's
what's let us grow
um we needed that Evolution because
without it there was never any space for
us you know the the forest canopy was
already covered by leaves that had
already taken up space
so yeah and you know to Circle back to
the animator thing for a second like a
byproduct of like all this
experimentation is we discovered that
if you take some drawings that you have
made that are consistent of a character
and they're finished and they're Inked
in the colored
with these new control net settings that
let you like really direct and control
the the output of these models you can
then just start taking sketches of these
same characters that you're making and
you can ink them and colorize them
automatically to look like your finished
drawings now imagine you're a
traditional animator and you have to sit
there and you have to ink and color
every single frame to final quality but
now you just have to ink and color like
the first frame and then all the rest of
them can just be your sketches instead
so you can still hand animate with that
tedium of having to like effectively
repeat yourself over and over and over
and sit there and meticulously draw
things that's only disappears like
that's a huge deal and it's sitting
right there
I feel like we're the only ones poking
at it which is weird
um but in a way it's like that's kind of
in the state of technology is like when
was the last time like multi-billion
dollar Investments for corporations
became
like tools that benefited animators
right
um traditional animators like what was
was the last big thing they got Wacom
tablets you know like was that the last
big one that was given to them and then
they're on their own for a while
drawing on the like those Microsoft like
whatever the studio those big screens
yeah the Wacom screens for that matter
yeah
so like we're seeing this kind of stuff
it's like dang this is so exciting and
like
I get people's fear and I get this you
know some some scariness out there but
it does make me sad to see so many
people
just angrily shutting things down when I
see these tools sitting right in front
of me like open source just waiting
waiting for somebody to like come out
here and like you know experiment with
them I think it's just context and time
man yeah give it some context and time
like you know just like when people hear
you say democratization and they don't
know Corridor and like that that's kind
of like a theme of our Channel they
freak out right because they don't know
the context they don't know like this is
literally what we do like we try to
democratize entertainment we're called
corporate Tech Bros yeah yeah
and that kind of tells you as much of
the context they have which is like this
guys red moment right there
it's like I've ever heard it so if
that's the amount of context they have
then you can't really take those takes
very seriously but like on the Aaron
Blaze video I saw a lot of people like
just even on the top comments they were
like you know thank you for making this
video and explaining to me I feel a lot
better about this now and I was freaking
out when I first saw corridors post like
so again like I feel like in Twitter the
internet in general is a bad place for
context yeah yes it's where context goes
to die yeah and be mutilated and you
know there is one there's also one
thought that's been put out I've seen it
multiple times and Nick you and I have
talked about this I think we talked
about today even look if you were
somebody who left a comment saying you
know I was interested in art school but
now that I saw this I'm wondering why I
even bother it's like I want to reach
the screen I just want to reach out and
grab you and Shake you and be like wake
up
shut up and stop that like that's not
how the world works you know it's like
Sam and I we studied painting
like black and white photography a few
of those we did some like basic ass
effects like I did like a freaking like
crappy sculpting class like yeah guys
all that stuff that we learned that
wasn't on computers we use it every day
every single day like yeah right those
fundamentals it's like somebody watching
like it's like somebody going to a
baseball game and seeing that the
Batters warm up with like an automatic
pitching machine but ugh
because I should even start bothering
playing baseball it's like yeah no like
learn those fundamentals learn all this
stuff because it doesn't matter what
tool you're using in the future
it's still human beings making things
for human beings like all that stuff
that you know all that stuff that you've
learned in art school from like
traditional mediums it's so important
like they're still painters out there
painting with paint because that stuff
matters and it hits can you imagine it
if yeah if everyone who went to college
and got a degree had to do the thing the
exact thing that they got the degree
I mean hell yeah society would have
collapsed a long time ago yeah yeah
I remember like when I was when I was in
our art video class with Sam there's a
magazine sitting on the tables there and
it showed the very first red one Digital
Cinema Camera it was a CG rendering and
it was all shiny aluminum it was it was
silver and it was like the big next big
thing in digital cinema and I didn't
look at that and go like whoa
I guess you just drop out of film school
like and I have to be parents also doing
a second major in film school at the
same time and like we're learning with
film cameras right we're not learning on
like there was no red camera like I
didn't see that like why am I even
bothering no it's like no learn all the
fundamentals on film and then look at
this and savor it and get excited
because it's just gonna get better like
everything that you learned it's just
gonna get easier and all the stuff that
you learned is just gonna make you more
powerful as an artist Don't You Remember
by the way like this this debate has
long been dead now for years but this
just finally reminded me it was digital
the film versus
a hot [__] debate for like a solid
like four or five years yeah totally
that was hilarious and the end it was
the met with the exact same level of
like fierceness of like yeah like
digital looks like [__] and it's bad and
also we shouldn't use it you know and
it's it's like it's the it's that
beautiful it was that intersecting
Paradox of like
it's gonna take over everything but it
also sucks and looks like [__] and it's
kind of like well bro you can't do both
you can't and AI just the same thing
it's like it does this does does it look
like [__] or is this actually really
cool and might change things I don't
know but it can't be both well here's
the thing maybe you actually can I think
it can because maybe the anime video
does actually look like [__] but still
is gonna change it so it's a beautiful
situation to be in right I can guarantee
I can guarantee you in five years we're
gonna look at that video and we're going
to see everything that's wrong with it
but that's because the technology and
the techniques will have improved not
because I mean
right yeah yeah there's so the long list
of things that are [__] but also amazing
you can I think everything in our
reality in our world was super shitty at
some point in time yeah you know like
computers
to the responses like the more negative
responses to with being like
corporations are just going to use this
to replace artists which is also a
strange way of thinking for me it's like
yeah more corporate art
well because I think the reality is when
something becomes easier to do
like the whole point of a corporation
doing it is because it's hard and
expensive to do you know it's it's like
making movies
have been hard and expensive hence why
you have giant corporations like Disney
Wonder Brothers Etc making them butter
Capital but when it becomes easy when a
group of 10 friends can make a movie
why do you need a corporation to do it
and like that's that's kind of the same
thinking about this this animation and
it's just it forces the corporations
quote unquote to start doing other
things like not to mention like just
look at like anyone who's listening to
us or watching this it's like this is
the exact example of that you know the
amount of watch time hours spent by like
a normal young person right now it's
like all right in the past when you had
to shoot on film or put something on
television like yeah that's that's the
amount of hours people spend watching TV
shows and movies now is really small
compared to now all these individual
independent creators yeah that are able
to you know create stuff easily yeah
exactly yeah and it's just like that's
gonna be it it's like we all want to
create at the speed of our own thought
we all want to just imagine our art and
then like make it real and manifest it
and everything we have all these tools
we have are just our way of trying to
get to that
as seamlessly as possible and when
something comes along that can make that
even more seamless
like the response isn't well I guess
it's just gonna let people just replace
artists and corporations like no artists
don't become artists because they want
to go work for a corporation you know
they become artists because they want to
make their art and ideally you don't
have to use a corporation but right now
a lot of things are really hard to do
and you need teams and you need money
and you need resources you need Hardware
but as that disappears then you don't
need it you can be independent yeah I
mean all the corporations even have a
leg up at that point exactly although I
mean actually I think the whole
Corporation angle already happened yeah
a long time ago it already happened
actually it started that way
they're shipping all the jobs overseas
by the way especially in the animation
industry yeah it's like I know whose
platform are we actually on right now
guys Google's platform or Apple's one or
are we on spotify's platform but on a
Android device also owned by Google you
know so so sorry the corporation's
already won guys yeah
can create a cell phone company
[Laughter]
that's some of the things we were
talking about last week we got our first
phone coming up there's gonna be 40
lenses on it yeah all right the whole
back is just different lenses the entire
back is lenses amazing
yeah but that's that's that's an
important point to make too like the
there's so many modern conveniences that
those types of organizations bring to
Modern Life
um but you know at the same time they
have their place and they have their
usefulness to whatever human endeavor
we're trying to do and you know in this
case allowing more people to be able to
distribute their ideas directly to the
people who want to see them more quickly
is the democratization of that art form
yeah that's very true if anyone wants to
know what the corporation making content
looks like just watch the like YouTube
Rewind videos
yeah if
gets a hold of it that's what they're
gonna make it'll be the most thumbs down
video in YouTube history
yeah maybe I should take over YouTube
it may not be solely responsible for why
they got rid of the thumbs down button
but it's about it
[Laughter]
they were the ones who got triggered by
seeing a thumbs down now
dude brought down by their own yeah
oh man so funny yeah I don't know it's
crazy stuff like
I understand people's fear at AI being
able to like replace artists but I
really don't think it's going to
um it can replicate a style
decently and that's about the extent of
it it can also like regurgitate kind of
you know machine learning based remixes
of what it's been fed which is I think
at its core what's happening with like a
lot of neural networks and like but that
can be so powerful when you can sculpt
that and use it as a tool
and you know it's like you can a
photocopier also lets you copy people's
art a scanner also lets you copy
people's art a camera also lets you copy
people's art like all these tools sure
they can let you copy someone else's
Style remix or stuff but
I feel like everybody collectively
forgot that we already have like really
strong cultural rules in place already
for this you know it's like oh this new
tool lets you also copy somebody's style
effectively
[__] I guess we need to make some laws
about this it's like wait I think it's
just because it's so new yeah but at the
time there's a new thing that concept of
copying isn't new at all no 100 not at
all but anytime there's a new
introduction of something that hasn't
been defined within the medium then you
have to ask all those questions again
like true I was looking at this piece of
work uh that was released last year
prior to the release of stable diffusion
um where this guy had made this piece
called The Crow you may have heard of
this yeah yeah I saw this email yeah and
and that is it's it's using a very
similar
like underlying technique where you know
it's it's creating a new look and tone
to to underlying footage but the
underlying footage is this um
choreographed
ballet dance uh and the person who did
the dance
um
authored it herself she came up with all
the moves and and the the whole thing
and uh then this guy came along and um
put a a bunch of filters and and looks
and tones on it to make it into
something different but and he's you
know and he he even won like a an award
at the Kane's Film Festival but I think
it was because nobody even knew what he
had done
I I think and yeah it was one of the
first it was one of the first like big
image to image videos yeah and so so the
underlying video is this like very
cinematically presented like performance
dance piece you know that clearly was
like okay a lot of work went into
filming this and capturing it and
choreographing it and all this stuff so
it was it was its own Standalone thing
and then he just took that and ran that
three image to image and then got like
an award so that's interesting it's like
what's what's worse than ethically
taking a loose loose-ish style like a
general style from something and
applying it well that's completely new
footage we're taking you know baked
footage that's already been shot I mean
that's clearly that's clearly a
um that's clearly a derivative work
that's not a fair use yeah so there's a
that's very clear distinction there
there's no difference like it's no
different than me applying a filter of
any other variety that have existed for
yeah like you make a short film you
spend you know 30 it's a 30 minute long
short film and I run that through
DaVinci and add like a cool like blue
filter on it I'll put a VHS on a VHS
effect and then I submit that to a film
festival it's like that's basically the
same thing here we are under simplifying
what it's like to AI process something
you do bring some imagery and attention
and things like that you know but
perhaps I mean ultimately okay I applied
10 filters to it you know and they're
very awfully you probably cut some shots
I really mess with the sliders so it
like really got a real dialed in all
right
really I think he redid the sound of
music I'm not sure but either way yeah
he redid that but but the fact of the
matter is like it's it's still very much
a a derivative from the original and the
person who created the original
dance
still I think would have a valid
argument to say hey that's copyright
infringement without my approval because
it's clearly derivative whereas when you
use your own footage and then you do
image to image now we're in a whole
different realm
um especially if you're creating your
own data sets too that that adds another
layer of like
originality to it but yeah yeah it's
nice to see the tools becoming
refined for what they are and what they
can do and not so much necessarily muddy
down and uh you know the the nefarious
implications of it all yeah and all the
style and data sets and all kind of
stuff yeah at the end of the day it's
like
oh that's you know well you you copied
the you know you copied some pictures
from a person and then you've trained an
AI on their style it's like that's okay
that's becoming become Irrelevant in you
know a few months when somebody else
makes a different data set with their
own stuff or you know somebody
customizes their own data set or you
know at this point there's thousands of
models available right
it's not the data set like it's not the
models it's like the underlying tool is
what the only thing that actually
persists and that's completely agnostic
of any data that's been fed into it you
know you can train it on the copyright
and stuff or non-copyright and stuff
it's still the same tool
um so I don't know it's it's I feel like
everybody got really caught up in the
not I keep saying everybody like it's
not everybody
a lot of the a lot of the ire a lot of
the the worries got really caught up in
this concept of like artists being
replaced
and I feel like I feel like that was low
hanging fruit for people to get views on
YouTube for and that's what they really
push as a narrative because that got
people really worked up and just I feel
like it's not really a reflection of
what is actually happening in reality
here with these tools and it's a little
too bad because it's I think it's
putting a lot of people off
what's kind of like the next Photoshop
you know whether it's specifically
stable diffusion or any of the other
things out there like these are
wonderful tools and they're not magic
they don't they're not robots they're
not sentient We Believe It or Not do in
fact know what's going on inside of
there it's not just some mystery machine
like it's really not it is the crazy
thing this is what's most excited about
like what makes me most excited about it
is it's not actually that complicated
like that's a that's the crazy thing
like let's say you want to get into like
genetics right like you got a lot of
work to get to being able to do anything
interesting in genetics you know but
like if you want to get into some
machine learning or like this diffusion
model stuff like you don't have to be a
doctor you don't have to spend years and
years and years studying it like the
underlying Concepts underlying math like
they're actually not that complicated
and that's really freaking cool and yeah
I get a little bit worried when I hear
people talking about how like oh this
general intelligence just knows all
these things that are happening it's
just become self-aware and it's just I'm
gonna Snap My Fingers I'm a whole movie
it's like nope nope that's not nope
that's magic this is not magic it's not
magic Dean had the video to video thing
uh loaded up the other day and then
we're you know because that whole Will
Smith eating Will Smith eating spaghetti
thing went viral and like that's great
because it's positive PR for AI but we
were trying like a bunch of prompts and
like it only seemed to be able to
generate images of like celebrities
doing stuff or eating yeah like it was
very limited yeah very simple things and
after we we put like you know a three
Factor prompt in there it just wasn't
able just gave us static noise because
at the end at the end of the day like
once again all you're doing is you're
teaching pattern recognition to a
statistical system on a computer it's
this is this is an example like so we've
been you know getting into fine-tuning
these models on our new data sets right
we're trying to figure out okay so let's
have pictures of of me in costume and I
have drawings of me and the same costume
how should I label these should I
technically label both of them as Nico
because I'm in both of them but then
label one set as photograph nailer said
his drawing
should I label the sets that are you
know drawings of me as the character and
just have to be completely independent
of the photos of me and label those as
something else because what's happening
at the end of the day is when you take a
picture you put a variable on it a word
a variable you take another picture and
you put a variable on it let's say it's
the same variable the computer is going
to load up these two pictures and
mathematically statistically speaking
just be like what's what's similar
between the two of them right it's just
gonna be a pure agnostic mathematical
point of view
so if I have three pictures
of a red ball and I have three pictures
of red square and I label those pictures
of a red ball as red ball and I label
those red squares as red square and I
feed them through the system the
system's gonna be like okay what
patterns do I notice well I noticed that
everything that's labeled with red tends
to contain the color red in it but the
things are red ball
have a different shape the things that
are red square so clearly the color must
be associated with this variable that's
red and those other variables must be
associated with visual shapes and like
it's this like is this low level just
statistically based pattern analysis
that's all that's happening here and
that's that's what's happening basically
with you know GPT 4 and chat gbt that's
basically what's happening with you know
diffusion models like and I'm granted
granted I'm oversimplifying but like at
the end of the day these are just fancy
statistical models that recognize
patterns and we just are trying to
figure out how do we trigger that to
like give us useful functions how can I
hook myself into that to like output a
coherent word or generate a picture of a
red triangle you know if I wanted to or
whatever you know so it's it's like the
more that we've used it here the more
like that magic has started to disappear
and the more realization of what's
actually happening and like I said we
know you're generating these movies of
celebrities eating things it's like
if you don't feed that model data
it can't create the data from nothing it
can only it can only make the reason
it's so good at Celebrities eating is
because it's been trained on celebrities
you know and it seems like food and like
you know yeah
but then that's that's when you start to
like realize as an artist like oh wait
this is where my power comes in because
this system just lets me statistically
represent things so now if I create
images and I feed them through the
system now I can start using the system
to empower me to like manipulate my
images to change my images to evolve my
images because the system's not
inventing things that it hasn't seen
before you as the artist still needs to
invent the thing that people haven't
seen before once you've done that you
can bring it into the system and be like
okay now I want I need I need a shot of
this character but a little bit from
this angle or I want to look a little
bit more like it's been you know
polished like cinematically framed or I
need some like Lighting on this like
that's lovely like to be able to like
just create your art yourself and then
use these tools to just magically
enhance them like yeah I don't know it's
crazy crazy stuff it's I'm so excited
for everything that's happening like I'm
excited for the stuff that we're making
I'm so jazzed that we can just like
realize these worlds and these visions
that we have the fact that like we're on
this cusp of basically being able to
make drawing like to animating an actual
sequence something where it's like the
computer just handles that the like the
factory line for you so you just
actually do the animation and all that
tedium of like inking every frame and
tying down every frame and coloring
every frame to look exactly like every
other frame that all just gets taken
care of for you automatically it's like
yes yes yes yes you know and I'm jazzed
about that when when more people can
make stuff and they're empowered to like
bring their vicious life you're gonna
get more art and you know what it's
gonna mean that there's a lot more out
there it might mean that you're not
getting like the giant 100 200 300
million dollar movies as often it might
not mean you're getting the mega budget
corporate Productions as often but
that's because people have so many more
options you know it's it's
it's almost gonna be like music and
that's in that sense where it's like we
have millions of bands out there now and
yeah there's still some big ones
but in a way it's almost like there's
more music but they're all smaller right
rather than like just having a single
gigantic acts that just dominated
I don't know yeah
there still are some acts that dominate
there are you know I think it's part of
the human condition yeah you know
there's always I mean yeah you could
have said the same thing about YouTube
too you know but but there are YouTube
creators like that everybody will
recognize you know or that everyone's
heard of
um and even this even this little micro
world that is YouTube Compared to
traditional television and movies has
done the same thing and so yeah I don't
see a reason why it would be a whole lot
different
than that also the other thing when it
comes to if if corporations are able to
harness these tools all they're going to
do is do some crazy stuff that nobody
else could do because they have such a
large team to do it which is also going
to be cool it's gonna they're gonna do
their own thing with it that that nobody
else can do with it and just like you
get with the Marvel movies now you know
you get with nobody else can do those
nobody else can do those movies
and they're super fun and people love
them but at the same time you're not
gonna get some you know like incredible
performance and drama where somebody's
gonna have a breakout in a new way of
Cinema you know it's not going to be
genre bending because that's too much of
a risk for them so don't expect that to
don't expect to find that there but yeah
yeah
I mean maybe maybe it will cause them to
create something other than just
rehashed stuff like the Marvel you know
well yeah there's there's too much risk
to be able to monetarily movie they're
gonna you know be able to use the comic
strips as storyboards and then animate
that [__] and there you go you have your
Marvel movies so maybe the corporations
will actually put money into original
stuff stuff that's really gonna stand
out it's definitely gonna require
Evolution that's for sure I hope so man
but that's what we want so you wanna you
always want to see things being pushed
you know yeah stagnant C stagnancy
stagnation stagnation
stagnation yeah
yeah yeah I mean Art's never been
stagnant ever
I challenge you to find me a five-year
period where Art's been stagnant and not
developed and not changed yeah
completely
yeah okay maybe like the Middle Ages but
I mean hey like I don't use any of the
same software yeah that I used when I
started
like doing this like it's all new stuff
to me
yeah yeah but I'm excited I don't know
I'm super excited I can't wait I was
telling you I can't wait to like see
what you can do for like like live more
live action style filmmaking like color
grading like you know like style
transfers and stuff on a on more of a
film scale yeah you take a bunch of
world war footage yeah yeah we were
talking about that like like train on
all the historical like you know World
War II footage and then yeah yeah but
separate separate the subject from the
style so you can apply the style to your
own footage and get that look or
something I've been seeing that's that's
really crazy is people have been using
this diffusion process to colorize and
restore old photographs we take the
black and white photograph and you run
it through a model that's meant to just
do photorealistic photography
um and because you have control that now
you can really lock down the forms and
shapes you get the exact same photograph
and now it's colorized and looks like
it's taken with a modern camera and it's
such a cool way to restore photographs
and like once temporal consistency has
been solved which I feel like we're
maybe half a year away from like
somebody coming out with like a real
solution for it like all black and white
films
instantly be able to be colorized like
we are so close to that right now it's
pretty crazy like
we're gonna be able to restore footage
from like the late 1800s and early 1900s
and have it look like 35 millimeter film
what about uh stuff that's out of focus
and interpolating into out of focus
images and things like that yeah you can
fix I mean at the end of the day the
computer is just imagining detail it's
it's going okay this is out of focus but
it looks like it's a face I've seen a
thousand or ten thousand a million faces
they generally have these consistent
traits so I'm just gonna fill it in the
best I can that's what the computer's
doing you know but yes you'll be able to
take something out of focus and put it
into Focus yeah granted it's you know a
bit of an imagined this is what it looks
like you know
um it's you know it's CSI enhanced but
well so so is digital in the first place
man because you're using pixels man
it's not an actual it's not actually a
true resolution isn't it weird like when
you like am ambiguate like
video to the point where it's like it's
just a grid of colored pixels yeah and
yet like we copyright it we tell stories
with it we get emotionally moved by it
and sometimes you see you see a certain
arrangement of pixels and you're like oh
yeah isn't that weird weird yeah it's
like oh man these little squares when
you laid them out with that color and
that pattern it really pissed me off
or it made me really sad
players made me sad again
it's weird I mean that shows you how
much like we're just running as like
neural networks in our brains too you
know oh yeah yeah because you stop
thinking about that and you're thinking
about just it being whatever story it is
yeah
yeah yeah neural networks in our brains
for sure it's very similar yeah I mean
well and before that it was just
capturing
an image as it was onto a piece of paper
and doing that at 24 frames a second
that's all yeah well yeah or scribbling
wacky symbols on a rock right yeah
meaning very meaningful symbols yeah
dude those symbols were super important
man you could you wouldn't go to the
after world if you didn't have those
symbols
on your on your tomb
Sam I've always felt like audio
is whoever audio is at now in terms of
technology and working with it is where
video will be in like 15 years Sam is
something that works a lot with audio do
you feel like that's
like the experience you see oh boy I
don't know yet everything from like the
speed to the ease of use to like how
quickly you can realize your vision I
mean it kind of hit a ceiling I feel
like
a while back
that's you know like there's I think
there's more
how do I say it like it yeah I mean I
feel like it hit a ceiling and in the
sense that like right now it's still the
same basic tools that were being used 10
years ago like there's some
stuff I think that is
that has progressed like oh like guitar
stuff has progressed a lot specifically
more than any other type of in my in in
my opinion of all the aspects of like
you know when it comes to audio and
engineering and stuff like you know 10
years ago
versus today like the guitar processing
and modeling and amplifiers have changed
a lot in the sense that now you can get
a tiny little box that flawlessly
replicates the sound of like any type of
like guitar amp you want and you can
like capture profiles it's not AI based
but you know there's that which is
pretty pretty intense because a long
time ago you can you can do that well
not even a long time ago but like you
couldn't do it with like good quality 10
years ago yeah
um so like there's that but like I feel
like still most of it's stagnated and I
think also too when it comes to AI tools
you know you look at stable diffusion
versus well it can make a more cohesive
image than like these AI music
generators can make a cohesive song or
even a cohesive
element in general and even I would even
say still with the like audio vocal
stuff right now it's still
it's not quite there but I I feeling I
feel like we're kind of on the cusp of
seeing something happen soon because we
you know those there's uh have you seen
the
there's like the stem tools now where
you can basically give the AI an AI
model a song and it'll basically it's
able to separate all the instruments
yeah that's really cool I dare you guys
to use an AI song in the next anime rock
paper scissors
that's the thing you know it's like it's
just it's just fun to make music though
still like wait you mean it's fun to
have a human experience yeah yeah yeah
yeah that means we don't do GPT scripts
here on quarter all the time yeah it's
like yeah who wants to just regurgitate
yeah yeah I know it's the easiest part
technically you know from a technical
standpoint writing it is the easiest
part yeah it's you know what if you
here's one more argument for the AI jobs
and all that stuff all right if you're
worried that AI is going to replace your
job as an artist if you're one of those
few out there who's in that Realm
just I just want you to know
and over the past six months
billions upon billions of anime girls
have been generated just the amount of
pictures of anime girls on planet Earth
has
quintupled about six months and people
still want to watch Regular anime so you
know like it already happened like
because it's gonna happen to you it's
already happened in the anime sphere
there's that's where all the
advancements happen they have in the
anime sphere they enter our regular
human sphere afterwards like I'm not
kidding like all anime girls probably
generated like this year then uh from
all of mankind like oh easily we're
talking B is not M's
okay yeah we're talking like the bees
let's just dish out random anime girl
for girl facts like honestly
at this rate like we got like just in
the in 24 hours right now there's more
anime girls being generated than in all
of like 80s anime we're generating 300
000 anime girls if you look at how many
anime girls were Illustrated in the 80s
when it comes to manga and film even
hand-drawn anime girls for a private
collection yeah right now in we are
generating every 24 hours that same
amount
you're not wrong it's probably even more
actually and there probably could even
be more
we don't know truly that's the scariest
part
there's no registry
we need a federal registry for all of
you yeah
oh my gosh those get into their wrong
hands yeah
so if you want if you want a little
preview of the future that awaits you
look no further than the anime girl uh
artist and see where they're at
I'm sure some of them have been replaced
by AI now that I think about it but you
know what
life Marches On so so far those bees of
anime girls haven't Associated the
demand yet though is what you're saying
so yeah in reality I think what we've
seen is that while you can generate
billions upon billions of synthesized
anime girls
everybody wants their organic homegrown
yeah all it did was handcrafted more
demand
yeah I I saw some pretty gnarly stuff on
that stable diffusion subreddit lately
that shocked me
but I it's too much of a topic to Spring
have you guys seen the Harry Potter to
introduce the next episode yes yes okay
so Nick you saw Harry Potter Valencia I
got Jacob have you seen Harry Potter
Balenciaga uh yes I did say okay yeah
yeah by the way I gotta give a shout out
to the original Harry Potter Balenciaga
demon flying fox somebody made a
tutorial on how to make Balenciaga
mid-journey videos now everybody's doing
them and just totally cop in that guy's
style demon flying fox you're the OG
just letting you know yeah um the
sequel's good too yep but
that's art somebody made art with AI
there it is
there it is Boom
course that's what I want to do
balenciagas but the next great adventure
yeah
Game of Thrones with billionaires in the
same style yeah it's Game of Thrones but
with billionaires and they're just
fighting about yeah the Joe Biden
hanging out with uh Obama and Trump
George Bush president's voice is one of
yeah that's so good the other over the
house like Michelle makes the best pizza
yeah
I just got the new doomslayer skin uh
fortnite you want to go back home and
get some juicy dubs
Hearts art also art
I love it can't it's cool it's new
medium heart without art guys
it sure is nice that you can actually
have
different art mediums exist and you only
have to replace the one or two because
you only have I mean we all know you can
only have like eight art mediums in the
world at any given time
um so you know one has to leave but I
think we've all been I think we've all
been waiting for uh sadly to get out of
here yodeling was yeah we're gonna yeah
yeah so air it's gonna replace The
Yodeling yeah um at some point we'll
replace uh oil painters but not yet yeah
yodeling replaced hieroglyphics right
yeah yeah we had a really good run
though I feel like it was a big stink
yeah
we should yeah like
just so the door is closing yeah get out
while you can yeah it is coming for your
job
number nine while you still have the
time okay I think yeah I can handle that
I think I think we can replace that nah
it's really cool though that in reality
that actually you can have new art
mediums come out and they just live
alongside all the other ones that are
still there yeah and that's just gonna
continue to be a thing it's really cool
that people still paint it's really cool
that people steal sculpt in the
claymation win an Oscar this year
Pinocchio stop motion stop motion sorry
I think they used claymation in it I
think they're not pretty clear involved
it looks like there's clay going on yeah
it's very cool
the texture yeah
if we ever get like okay
I'm like the omeos
did you come here
little twists in the old classic
Pinocchio
so was did your hands were hands really
dirty after you had to model all that
clay
[Laughter]
you're pretty good at making
I'm always wondered how do you get the
clay to like stand up
doesn't the clay dry out like
a shot yeah like if you don't do the
shot fast enough the clay dries out
yeah see clay
a handful of times
that Medium yet yeah it's still hanging
around there Clay is still it's your
favorite thought that when they saw the
cgt wrecks in Jurassic Park that that
was it for claymation
I just bought a [__] ton of clay
all these [__] all these garbage
trucks all the garbage I just bought a
bunch of clay mining shares
yeah they're they're driving their
rubbish trucks around and they're like
wow there's a lot of clay
who's throwing up are we on the Bank of
America
Jurassic Park
wow
is like wait what oh god I gotta call my
brother he's a broker in New York
he runs a clay mine in Philadelphia yeah
luckily that that boomed like a nice
resurgence
[Laughter]
damn man well the point is that they're
still using clay it's here to stay like
I don't know what lessons you should
take away from the end of this podcast
that's funny it's like yeah I don't know
if you guys know but I'm still sitting
on a clay behind it
I think we got like 10 good pinocchios
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I've been hanging on this clay
for like 30 years
some people said I was crazy in 93 they
said I was nuts to hang on to Clay but
here I am yeah 30 years later and look
at me now I got it I got enough for ten
I got enough for ten claymations any
[__] Disney [__] me over they had a
contract to buy a whole shitload of it
and then they filmed it in live action
they bought me out for a tenth of the
chairs that's a goof all right that's
what a bit guys what a bit what a bit to
end it on you know what I'm saying the
for last year
on the corner pass right that's that's
how it always goes I like to imagine
that that's what the CEO of Leica
Studios actually did yeah
Tim Burton is like sitting there all
right Jake plans out all righty
[Music]
in here
to me
[Music]
you better put that [__] in a [__]
tone right now
put your put that in a kiln right now
burn it
I'm just finished the pottery oh it's
just doing a pottery just make a little
after what's that 35 millimeter camera
doing in your pocket
65 millimeters
laughs oh we're still going that's it
all right bye everybody see you later